[Music]
as women's History Month draws to a
close we want to focus today's money
watch on the gender pay Gap it's barely
improved over the last 20 years just
look at these numbers in 2002 women
earned on average 80 percent of what men
earned and in 2022 20 years later women
still only earned 82 percent as much as
men it's even worse for women of color
data research from the Pew Research
Center showed that black women earned 70
percent as much as white men in 2022 and
Latino women earned 65 percent as much
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger joins us right now good
morning how you doing I'm doing well all
right so um more women graduate from
college than men same goes for law
school and about half of medical school
graduates are women so why hasn't this
um gender gap improved yeah it's a it's
a curious combination of bad factors at
first we were thinking maybe it's
because women tend to dominate
low-paying feels make Child Care Home
Health Care and then we started to look
at other professions and we found across
many professions most professions if you
compare men and women men still make
more money regardless of the profession
so that's really curious doing the same
job doing the exact same job so then
there's one level deeper that I think is
quite fascinating it looks at Parenthood
now think about it women have the baby
they take themselves out of the labor
force often when they come back in they
are earning less now let's look at a
father there is something that's called
the fatherhood premium a father who's in
the workforce has presumably someone
helping at home tends to work more and
longer than men who don't have children
so it's as if the men who have kids make
more money than men without kids women
who have kids make less money than
anybody yeah the men aren't penalized
for having children no they're actually
it's like one is rewarded yeah men and
then women it's held against them
exactly right and I think that there's a
lot of implicit and explicit bias but I
think that there's this kind combination
of factors that are playing here that
are leaving this Gap persistently wide
yeah I mean there's a story in the news
right now with Sharon Stone who says
that she was paid five hundred thousand
dollars for uh Basic Instinct Michael
Douglas was paid 14 million now listen I
know she she says like I was new he was
a big star but that still seems like a
gross significant yeah that's a
significant difference well I'll tell
you in some sectors where it really is
glaring is that we see a sector like
nursing a lot of nurses used to be that
field used to be dominated by women now
more and more men have come in well
guess what The Men Who come in seem to
be making more than the women who've
been there so there is a gap and it
persists and we have got to address go
ahead we know this exists generally but
people are actually wondering where they
work is this happening they're looking
at their co-workers and wondering what's
happening I remember I worked at a
magazine once but for some reason the
printer started shooting out everybody's
salary it was like a big spreadsheet and
we all gathered around and then we
looked over at Barnett where our Baron
we were like Barrett
yeah you're doing about twenty thousand
dollars better than everybody
uh so but should people just be talking
about it more not waiting for the
printer error well I think that the
transparency argument is really a good
one now remember we have a lot of states
that have started to say you've got to
put a range out for the jobs that you're
hiring for right and I think this is
good news employers get really freaked
out about this they don't want to do it
there's pushback it actually improves
morale because it makes you feel like if
the system is fair and I know what it is
I work harder but when we talk about
having transparency I think a lot of it
has to do with people talking with one
another this is very helpful for women
to do you go out and you say okay I'm
Jill I'm working at an organization I
want to talk to another friend maybe not
doing the exact same thing as me but
getting some guidance what are you
making what are your conversations like
if this is completely Oddball to you
Gail you and I are from a generation we
didn't talk about this I was raised not
that it was very impolite and you didn't
ask your co-worker what do you make you
do it more casually I'm trying to find a
way to increase my pay what is the range
that's here how can I get this
conversation going maybe going to a
mentor maybe to go someone else in the
organization that's really been looking
after you it makes it so important
because this kind of transparency leads
to better outcomes and by the way the
system can't just be where you're only
talking to women you've got to go across
and talk to the other genders and find
out who's there don't be protective oh
and by the way many organizations frown
on this if you talk to many people in
organizations they'll say my boss told
me I was getting a raise but I shouldn't
tell anybody else it's the unwritten
rules and by the way how did that happen
too that is illegal it is perfectly
legal for everybody to share their
information bosses and managers please
you should encourage that because you
want a fair system as well super
interesting you're the best I appreciate
you we can talk all day about this oh
yes